the opening scene is set in the year
2036 and we learn that Earth has been
taken over by an alien race known as the
V that's not an intimidating name their
arrival has resulted in widespread
unemployment and homelessness among
humans while the aliens live in
luxurious floating cities above the
planet despite this tragedy the Vu
assert that they are here to improve
human civilization we then cut to a high
school student named Adam Campbell who
has a passion for art and painting he
lives with his mother Beth and his
sister Natalie after their father
abandoned them Beth a lawyer by
profession is currently jobless but they
are fortunate enough to have a home
unlike many who are homeless one day
Natalie is seen trying to grow their own
food in the garden because all they get
is the artificial stuff provided by the
aliens meanwhile Adam is trying to paint
a view of the sky but at the same time
the alien floating city parks right
above their place blocking The View
completely the sky is a stupid idea for
a painting anyway at school Adam is seen
attending his final English class during
which students are given a device that
connects their minds and they watch a
presentation from the aliens after the
presentation the English teacher
announces his forced retirement because
the aliens want humans to adopt Vu
culture and replace human labor with
machines in this way the school doesn't
waste money on the teachers later Adam
notices a new student named Khloe in his
art class he seems to be drawn to her
and as a result he strikes up a
conversation Adam learns that Khloe's
family is homeless and they've been
living under a bridge after class the
duo is making their way out when they
are startled by the sound of a gunshot
upon turning back they learn that their
English teacher has committed the
unthinkable this implies how tragic and
depressed the humans have become ever
since the aliens arrival the English
teacher could have waited at least a
couple more minutes so the students
didn't have to hear that neverthe
theless considering Khloe's dire
situation Adam invites her family to
come stay at their house during dinner
Khloe's father Mr Marsh expresses
gratitude to Beth for the meal and
Promises to pay rent once he finds a job
Beth is surprised by The Mention Of rent
as she thought they were only staying
for the night in response Adam explains
that he promised Khloe they could stay
in their basement for as long as they
needed enraged Beth takes her son aside
to reprimand him in private just because
the girl makes things hard for you
doesn't mean she has to make things hard
for all of us but Adam believes there's
nothing wrong in helping needy people
especially the ones he wants to bone on
the weekend Khloe invites Adam to join
her in Scavenging for items she takes
him to a location where the aliens
discard objects from their floating
cities She searches the area in hopes of
finding something valuable to sell and
earn some money while they search Adam
shares a story about his father a real
estate developer who received an offer
to build housing for the aliens however
he declined due to unfair terms and
shifted to California instead amidst
their conversation Adam sketches a
portrait of Chloe Upon returning home he
finishes his artwork and shows it to
Chloe who likes it their conversation
eventually takes a romantic turn and
just as they are about to kiss Khloe's
father interrupts them sensing something
am Miss he keeps the curtain open
preventing them from engaging in any
private activities suddenly Adam doesn't
feel so good about giving these people a
home the next next day at school khloee
attempts to sell the scavenged items to
generate rent money for Beth but she can
hardly get anything sold as a result she
comes up with another way to earn money
she tells Adam about a device that
allows couples to broadcast their lives
to the aliens who find human romantic
love intriguing this process known as
the courtship broadcast pays couples for
sharing their romantic stories Chloe
asks Adam if he would be willing to
partner with her Adam hesitates saying
that he prefers privacy and it's
uncomfortable to feel someone peeking
into their love life however Chloe
insists that everything will remain
natural eventually convincing Adam from
that day onward the two begin their
romantic relationship while broadcasting
it to the aliens the device attached to
their foreheads records their
experiences and emotions it also
announces the number of viewers and the
money they earn which Adam finds
somewhat disturbing as days pass their
relationship deepens resulting in more
viewers and increased income within a
few days they are able to afford better
food and the families are more than
happy to have such food after a long Gap
even during the dinner time Khloe tries
to record the conversations about family
and love but Beth tells her not to bring
business to the table after dinner Adam
tries to have some private time with
Khloe without the device but she insists
on keeping it on which saddens him one
day Mr Marsh and Khloe's brother Hunter
try to learn the alien language which is
based on sounds
a short while later Beth arrives and
notices the two using her computer
without asking for permission first this
prompts her to confront them saying that
they should respect the boundaries
Hunter becomes upset and leaves and Mr
Marsh expresses his displeasure as Beth
embarrassed him in front of his son
their discussion soon escalates into an
intense argument leading both families
to raise their voices before long Beth
shuts everyone up and claims that they
must create some house rules going
forward following this incident the two
families have dinner separately the
dispute between their families creates
tension between Khloe and Adam despite
this they try to continue broadcasting
their moments but their lack of focus
results in a low number of viewers in
addition Adam gets even more
uncomfortable because he feels that
they're just pretending to be a couple
for the sake of the broadcast one day
while at school Adam and Khloe receive a
letter from the alien broadcasting
commission ABC they ask one of their
classmates to translate it only to
discover that they are facing a lawsuit
from the Broadcasting Company in order
to discuss the matter they are taken to
one of the floating cities in a flying
bus upon arrival they are picked up by a
man in a golf cart they are surprised to
learn that humans also work in the alien
City it turns out the man used to be a
neurosurgeon but the aliens chose him to
work there as a driver hearing this Adam
thinks that it's sad but the man claims
that he's making way more money than he
did as a surgeon a short while later the
driver drops them off at an opening in
the middle of a golf course and
instructs them to enter inside they
encounter an Alien named Shirley
receiving a massage from a human woman
the alien communicates via sound
produced by rubbing its palms and a
computer translates it into human
language Shirley accuses them of
deceiving their viewers since they are
not in love any longer the duo wonders
if Shirley can read their hidden
emotions to which she explains that
years of studying human emotions have
enabled the aliens to understand
understand matters of the heart and
biological changes surely demands that
they repay all the money earned through
the broadcasts or face a lawsuit
burdening them with a huge debt spanning
six Generations unable to afford such a
debt Khloe proposes an alternative they
can continue the broadcast but with
different partners this heartbreaking
suggestion deeply affects Adam but
surely accepts it on their way back Adam
demands an explanation for her decision
in response she makes him realize how
romance is not her priority as food and
shelter are upon arriving home Beth
checks the contract and admits there's
nothing to do because the alien lawyers
are too powerful to confront however she
is concerned about the potential harm
legal action could bring her son so she
decides to visit Shirley to generate
some other way out once there Beth
acknowledges her son's mistake but she
still tries to present the case with a
different perspective she explains that
there are various ious forms of Love
highlighting a mother's love for her
children as one of the most powerful
knowing that surely also has a child
Beth says that she must understand
eventually Shirley agrees not to sue
Adam and Chloe under one condition if
her son temporarily gets to be in a
relationship with humans after returning
home Beth informs her children that
Shirley's son will be living with them
and she will be acting as his wife for
the time being Adam and Natalie cannot
digest the fact that they will need to
consider an alien as a part of their
family but they don't have any other
choice in the next scene Beth marries
the alien in front of a small group of
people during the marriage ceremony Adam
is even more devastated to see Chloe
broadcasting love with another guy after
marriage the alien starts living
together which Adam and Natalie do not
particularly enjoy one day at school
Khloe tries to talk to Adam expressing
concern for his well-being however Adam
who is deeply hurt ref refuses to listen
and walks away when he arrives home the
alien welcomes him and asks for a hug
Adam responds rudely you're not my dad
prompting a scolding from his mother
later that night Adam is awakened by a
sound he grabs a bat and cautiously
descends the stairs to investigate only
to discover that his biological father
Mr Campbell has sneaked into the house
to speak with him after a brief
father-son conversation Mr Campbell asks
about his wife and wonders if she has
moved on Adam feeling anxious about
seeing his father after such a long time
excuses himself and rushes to the
bathroom to hide his emotions while he's
away Mr Campbell secretly Peaks into his
wife's room and finds the alien sleeping
on top of her yeah sleeping this sight
shatters his heart prompting him to
leave soon Adam walks out of the
bathroom and feels sad to see his father
walking away a few days later Adam and
Natalie attend school where they notice
all the students Gathering outside
shortly afterward the principal
announces that the school is shut
shutting down because the aliens will be
providing education through their nodes
due to this all the students are
instructed to return home regardless
Adam stays a little longer staring at
the school building after a while he
notices that the building's doors and
windows are being covered suddenly an
idea strikes him and he decides to
utilize that space as a massive canvas
meanwhile at home the alien after
watching old school Hollywood films
wants Beth to act like these
conventional wives as a result he orders
her an apron and a blonde wig asking her
to put it on just then Beth receives a
call from a workplace where she had left
a resume months earlier excited Beth
decides to visit the workplace but the
alien stops her claiming that his wife
doesn't have to work this Sparks the
argument between the two Beth soon
carries the alien away turns off the TV
and leaves all of their conversation is
overheard by Mr Marsh who then
approaches the alien to offer him help
later that evening Beth and her children
return home and are taken AB to find
Marsh Dawning the apron and wig Marsh
claims that he has accepted the alien's
offer and is assumed the role of the
alien's wife Beth and her kids hardly
control their laughter at his utter
desperation over the next few days Adam
dedicates himself to creating a mural on
the school's wall on the other hand
Khloe starts feeling more and more
isolated due to Adam's distance and her
father's obsession with superiority
eventually Adam completes his miral
which symbolizes the immense difficulty
the aliens have brought to human lives
shortly after Shirley's son happens to
pass by and notice the mural he then
asks about its purpose to which Adam
replies that it represents the spirit of
human resilience the following day Adam
is summoned to the school where he finds
a crowd gathered it turns out that the
alien has brought his mother and an Art
Expert to inspect the mural after this
Shirley offers him a huge opportunity to
become an artist and Residence at their
facil facility with a substantial salary
with everyone applauding him Adam finds
it hard to turn down this opportunity
ultimately deciding to accept the next
morning a small circular spacecraft
lands outside Adam's residence and he
boards it after bidding farewell to his
family this spacecraft transports him to
the alien planet where he is Led through
a dark tunnel leading to an auditorium
filled with numerous aliens much to his
shock the aliens have taken his painting
from the school wall s and brought it
there after modifying it now the
painting symbolizes that the humans are
very happy to live with the aliens
following this Adam is asked to spread
this propaganda through his art Adam who
always sought truth through his art is
unable to digest this so he immediately
returns to earth he apologizes to his
family for not being able to make it and
they quickly forgive him it's okay that
you didn't sell out son that night Adam
is unable to sleep so he decides to go
to his school schol and start his new
mural that aligns with his beliefs there
he finds Chloe who also couldn't sleep
finally the two reconcile their gaps
apologizing to each other the movie ends
with the two of them starting to work on
a new art project titled landscape with
invisible hand subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching